a lot of times the screenings in Seattle
they're not in 3d or 2d usually I'm fine
with that because I'm kind of over three
- okay that's a gimmick but I just want
to see the movie just give me the movie
but How to Train Your Dragon 3 I would
have liked to have seen this one in 3d
something about - How to Train Your
Dragon movies they're just they're an
experience in 3d so great in 2d though
of it been cool
[Music]
How to Train Your Dragon 3 or the hidden
world it's called that - so how did
train your dragon the hidden world is
the third chapter the final chapter of
the How to Train Your Dragon trilogy the
epic chapter that is because these
movies are pretty awesome it continues
the adventures and friendship of hiccup
and toothless han and chewie frodo and
sam hiccup and toothless in this one i
find out toothless isn't the only night
fair he's not the last night fury ER i
guess he is because this new one's a
light fury boy who's toothless wants to
get a girlfriend all the while there's
this new guys like alright I'm gonna
kill that dragon and take the rest of
them he's kind of a horrible human being
who just wants to kill toothless and
once again like I said in the beginning
of this review I felt like I already
told you I really dug this movie
everything with toothless was really
what I liked in his movie you can say
toothless and hiccup but I really like
toothless their scenes where he's just
flying around with this new light fury
and I was like this is this captivating
stuff this is a captivating character a
moment with a character that never talks
also the sand effects I don't know why
it's just stood out to me there's a
scene on this beach involving toothless
spinning around and basically sands just
flying everywhere
sand effects were crazy good this is one
of those rare occasions where I think
this movie could have been longer if the
movie was longer you could have fleshed
out the villain a bit more you get a
couple of scenes with him as it stands
it's just a really bad dude who just
wants to capture or kill toothless also
the movie felt a little jumpy like after
the intros how to train your dragon
movies the intro to the movie like this
setup always takes a little bit to hook
me but once it hooks me gets its hooks
into me and it doesn't let go this movie
is no different than the other two in
that respect but location wise it does
feel like our jumps from here to there
and then there's this other Island they
go to and then they go back over there
you can argue they're a bit more nomadic
in this movie than they have been before
it's a little graph there's me looking
for stuff didn't take away from the
experience as a whole and when it's
going down exciting almost doesn't quite
cover it I feel like it's gonna be a
while in 2019 before I get another movie
that gives me this kind of excitement
and the action sequences where I'm like
oh my gosh that is thoroughly danger
flying narrowly escaping the obstacle
they're dealing this is basically this
is something to address about the whole
trilogy of How to Train Your Dragon I
love that hiccup has constantly evolved
hiccup has constantly grown it's not
like he's always a kid he's growing he's
the leader of this group of Viking he
has to make the calls but given his
character and what you know about I mean
know he's not gonna feel like he's up to
it he's not gonna feel worthy and that's
a huge part of this movie and by the end
I left with one word which is fulfilled
I felt really fulfilled at the end of
this movie the end of this movie made
this install
this movie feels fulfilling but also
make the trilogy has a whole feel
fulfilling feel like I might like the
second one I don't know which one I like
more the second or the third one I just
saw the movie once like an hour ago but
the fact is that carries the torch and
sticks the landing for the How to Train
Your Dragon movies if you didn't like
the first two you're definitely not
gonna like this one this is for fans of
How to Train Your Dragon if you do love
the last two How to Train Your Dragon
movies treat yourself watch How to Train
Your Dragon the hidden world so I will
say How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world is awesome tacular very few bonds
are as strong as a person and their pet
but that doesn't even make sense because
toothless is more than a pet it's family
I guess that's the point there's no bond
to strongest family and that's the
family you choose it could be friends
who aren't your siblings not by blood
anyway it could be your pets that's our
family I've god I'm going on a tangent
here this movie brings out emotions can
you tell I so How to Train Your Dragon
the hidden world have you seen it watch
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you